so I've been thinking about the 4B movement
sorry my cat is here
right by my face um
I'm thinking about the 4B movement and how our generation um
or maybe this is just like America in general and like
our anti intellectualism um
we are like obsessed with hard and fast rules to things
which I think is a symptom of our lack of critical thinking skills in America
and the fact that like
we are just very much taught
that you have to just do what someone else tells you
I feel like the left really suffers from this
even though it is a side effect of like
growing up in a right wing authoritarian country
so with the 4B movement specifically
and this is far from the only place where this shows up
because I think that it popped up with election discourse a lot
but with the 4B movement
it's just interesting that feminists have been saying for years and years now
that like
women need to decenter men
you need to like
you know disengage from like
all the heterosexual patriarchal like propaganda
like all of this
and then obviously it didn't catch on too much
I mean there has been an increase in like
women being independent from men um
but now like
everyone's talking about the 4B movement
and like there are a lot of criticisms
completely valid criticisms coming of it
like I think if we actually could get a considerable percentage
of women in America on board with having a strict boycott of not dating
not having sex with men not getting married
not having children like
I think that would be we would see results
but so many women are going to keep dating and keep sleeping with men
and they're going to like
say like oh
like I stand in solidarity with the feminists and the 4B movement
but like I found a good one
like my man is the exception and there are good men in the world
might be controversial to
to hear from someone who is a very far left like feminist
but I don't believe that men are 100% inherently evil
um I think that actually like
kind of feeds into bio essentialism a little bit
though that might be a TikTok for another time
is that why they say the 4B movement in Korea is terfy
I actually had no idea why people say that
it's like full of terfs but is that it
is it because of the bio essentialism of it anyway
how come that when we say decenter men
it's not very effective but then you talk about the 4B movement
just launching a very strict boycott of all things heterosexual and patriarchal
then all of a sudden people are really interested